recordings
[Music]
North on topic just taking a left on
North Church
Northwest at North Church
light traffic
[Music]
[Applause]
we're heading north on York
flight traffic
[Music]
just went through the red light on West
River New York
the speeds are about 40.
all right female driver sunglasses
straight black hair
going up on the grass
[Music]
Powers jeweler did you stopping
negative she's going through the grass
again
[Music]
Southbound on Pearl
speeds about 35.
[Music]
still Southbound on Pearl passenger
Rochelle
they got somebody with sticks
find my phone
passing Mandalay speeds 40.
[Music]
still southbound passing pairs for
speeds 40 check flight
[Music]
taking it right on 130th
scored about 130th speeds 40 traffic
monitor
opinion
[Music]
passing big freak
[Applause]
[Music]
speed's about 50.
still Northbound speeds go through
traffic light
extremely fancy
coming off the Huffman
[Music]
went through a red light on Huffman
still no family stuff
for 130th
speeds are about 50.
coming up to the plaza
[Music]
coming up the snow
driving on the oncoming traffic
over the curb and snow
going left on Snow
[Music]
over there
come again
yes we're going out
westbound on snow light traffic
let's be 50.
passing Ben weird
passing Michael
speeds 44 still Westbound and snow
coming up the Smith Road
taking her right on Smith
North on Smith passing renmore
coming up to Hummel Road
speeds are 50 traffic light
coming up to Commerce Park
coming up to Elm going through the red
light
foreign
Park
taking a left on Brook Park
last time Brook Park
speeds are 50 traffic light coming up to
West 164th
coming up to Henry Ford going through
red light
going through the red light by the RTA
Station
driving in the middle of the road
still West
taking a right on Rocky River
Northbound on Rocky River
turning onto Maplewood
foreign
[Music]
driveway
taking her right heading toward back
Rocky River Road
[Music]
six six did she throw something out of
the window I saw her hand come out
taking a right on Rocky River
[Music]
Southbound on Rocky River passing
Maplewood again
40 traffic light
driving up to the center lane coming up
to Brook Park
East on Brook Park
fees are about 60.
just passing the RTA Station
coming up the Henry Ford
in the turning lane
coming off to West 164th
was that a hit
foreign
weeds are about 70 miles an hour
from the West Mountain from the Rocky
River Drive again
coming up through a red light the
highway off ramp
driving in the center lane two flat
tires left side
swings
here
I just like another man here
we're at the intersection of Rocky River
or Park Road so that's why I made a
third vehicle in the dark blue Jeep
companies
still westbound Brook Park
there we go it appears that she was
intentionally trying to push another
um we're coming up to the bridge here
come into pair of your car if you can
give them a call let them know
something great
it looks like we're going to go
um
two tires
foreign
oh
six six is directly behind it keep your
wall don't let any cars pass you
for the sun back and forth between Lane
Direction
um do have traffic behind us now that
looks like we're coming to a stop here
[Music]
get on the fucking vehicle get out get
out of the vehicles
get out
here we're good
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my God